Nathaniel is with us in Colorado
what do you thankful for Nathaniel hi
Dave I'm thankful to God for my wife and
my five month old son is that love it
cool how can I help today well thank you
so much for taking my call
essentially my wife and I we bought a
home in May and this is performing about
the baby steps or Dave Ramsey anything
of that sort and since then we've gone
through Financial Peace University we
are one hundred and twenty eight
thousand dollars in debt our income is
one hundred and fifteen thousand however
my wife at the end of this school year
wants to stop working which I'm a
hundred percent supportive of and that's
forty-five thousand dollars worth of our
income so her last paycheck will be in
July of next year and we're trying to
discern whether or not we should sell
our home if we sell it when she quits
will the house payment be more than 1/4
of your take-home pay yes what will it
be
percentage of your total of your
take-home pay when she quits it will be
about fifty five percent of my take-home
pay I'm currently looking for another
job to kind of make up for her pay but
even with her pay it's about 35 to 40
percent yes I would sell the house okay
perfect in order in order for her to
stay home that house has to go okay cool
and I think my follow-up question to
that is right now we're in Colorados the
markets a little bit crazy and about but
if we were to sell it right now the
reveal is telling us that you probably
have to pay about five to ten thousand
dollars just in the closing cost and
stuff so that would go into our debt but
if we were to wait till the spring we
could have essentially avoid that and
even make about five to ten thousand
dollars would you just sell it right now
and not even worry about it
or wait into this thing it doesn't
matter it's got to be gone before she
can come home okay cool because you
cannot survive on a house payment of
fifty-five percent of your take-home pay
that will crush you
it's just mathematically you're gonna
have trouble even paying lights and
water and stuff
much less talking about any kind of
prospering so the house has to be gone
so like Feb 1 second the market that's
about the latest because it had if she
wants to quit in May because you can't
take a chance cuz listen if the house is
not gone in May she can't quit
she can't you got to pay the bill and
you cannot make it on fifty five percent
of your payment being of your of your
take-home pay or be in the house payment
you just can't do it so you know I'm
gonna make sure if job one
if goal one is her coming home to be
with this baby which is what sounds like
we're talking about and I'm on with that
that's fine but you have to adjust your
expenses to fit your income then you
can't have your cake and eat it too
you can't live in that house with you
know fifty thousand dollars less income
it's tough to live there now it's
impossible to live there after she quits
so it's just got to be gone whatever
that means
you know but I would say February 1st is
when I'm putting it on the market